acusado de homicidio involuntario George
Álvarez es el hombre que atropelló con
su automóvil y causó la muerte de ocho
personas que esperaban el autobús al
frente de un centro de inmigrantes en
Brownsville Texas avanzan las pesquisas
para determinar si el conductor embistió
a propósito
hay una investigación masiva en curso
para identificar exactamente lo que
sucedió Y esperan que salga información
donde puedan contarle al público mucho
más sobre lo que pasó si fue intencional
o no
las circunstancias del conductor y
seguir trabajando con respecto a las
víctimas
las primeras investigaciones apuntan a
que Álvarez perdió el control de su
vehículo al no respetar una señal de
tránsito Álvarez Fue presentado ante la
Corte y se ordenó su detención con una
fianza de más de 3 millones de dólares
dada su extensa historia criminal en un
comunicado el gobierno de Venezuela
pidió a las autoridades que investiguen
el incidente Venezuela exhorta las
autoridades estadounidenses
correspondientes a investigar en
profundidad los hechos y esclarecer sus
causas con el fin de descartar cualquier
intencionalidad relacionada a las
prácticas de odio y xenofobia contra el
pueblo venezolano que se han expresado
en el pasado uno de los migrantes que
viven en el centro mencionó que uno de
sus amigos hacía parte de las víctimas
nuestros compañeros los que con los que
compartíamos las habitaciones
compartimos conversaciones
echábamos cuenta y de todo ubicado al
norte de la fronteriza ciudad mexicana
de Matamoros Brownsville ha visto un
aumento de la afluencia de migrantes en
los últimos días debido al inminente fin
del título 42